where we double the number
of times U is applied for each control Qubit.
Here in this diagram I've indicated this by including the powers
on U inside of the boxes rather than showing the controlled U gate
being applied that many times, as a way of both making
the diagram more clear and saving on space so
that it fits on the screen.
Now the first thing that we need to notice
about this procedure is that it might become very expensive.
In particular we're
doubling the number of times each U operation gets applied
for each control Qubit.
And if the way that we do this is simply to iterate a controlled U gate however many times we need,
we're going to get a huge circuit. It'll be exponentially
large in the number M.
That's a major limitation in general, and in particular it limits our ability to get precise approximations
of eigenvalues.
In the specific case of factoring though, which we'll get to shortly, it turns out that we're very fortunate and we can play a trick that allows us
to avoid this exponential blow up in cost.
But in general for arbitrary
unitary operations U, this won't be possible and
we'll pay a steep price
for increasing the
number of control qubits.
I'm not going to go
through a detailed analysis of the circuit in this video and instead I'll just mention that there is a fairly simple
expression for the state
just prior to the measurements which is shown here on the screen.
From that state we can get an expression for the probabilities
of the various outcomes, and it happens to look like this.
And once we have this expression,
we can reason about it, and really this expression
is all we need to carry on.
Like I said, I'm not gonna get into
the details in this video, but you can find them in the
written content for the lesson and it turns out that it's
actually not that complicated,
so check it out if you're so inclined. If we do go through the analysis, what we find is that the situation
is not all that different
from the M equals two case, except that we get more precision.
In particular, we can think
first about the probability to get the very best or one of
the two best approximations,
which we can express like we have here.
You can ignore this subscript of a one on the absolute value if you like.
This is just a symbol that we
can use to remind ourselves that we're talking about
approximations on the circle where we think about theta equals zero
and theta equals one as being the same. The point here is that
we're thinking about whatever choice of Y makes Y over two to the power M
as close as possible to theta.
And once again, just like we
had for the M equals two case, we're guaranteed to get this outcome Y with probability at least 40%.
In fact, the probability is
at least four over pi squared, which is a little bit more than 40%.
10 is not a bad
approximation to pi squared when you're in a hurry.
And that's actually pretty remarkable. What we're talking about is getting the very best
approximation to theta as a fraction Y over two to the power M
where Y is an integer. And we're getting the
very best approximation with probability greater than 40%.
We can also think about
approximations that are worse.
Specifically let's imagine
that Y isn't quite so good, and more specifically let's suppose
that there's a better
approximation to theta of the same form that lies between theta and Y over two to the M,
which can be expressed as
is written on the screen.
In such a case the
probability to get this Y will be relatively small, at most 25%.
It'll actually be lower than that, but 25% is what we get from
a pretty simple analysis, but it's good enough.
As an example. Here's the plot we get when we use three control
qubits rather than two.
This time I'm only
plotting the probabilities for the outcomes three, four, and five because I don't want the
figure to be too messy.
When theta is equal to
one half for instance, we're guaranteed to get the outcome four.
And so we take our
approximation to be four eighths or one half because two to
the power three is eight.
And in this case we're exactly right. And as long as theta is closer to one half than it is to say three
eighths for instance,
we get the outcome four with a probability higher
than the outcome three.
And with probability,
again larger than 40%.
Here's the plot when M is equal to four. And the curves actually
look pretty much identical, except that now we've zoomed
in by a factor of two.
So now the outcomes that are plotted include seven, eight, and nine and we're taking the approximation to be one of these numbers
divided by 16 rather than eight.
And I'll show one more plot where we increase to M equals five.
And again we're gonna be
zooming in by a factor of two.
And here it is. Once again the curves look
pretty much identical, but we're effectively
doubling our precision.